Je dis cela pour encourager la transparence, vous pouvez vous asseoir.
(Rires)
Ceux d'entre vous qui ont reconnu le premier groupe de noms savent
que c'étaient des Afro-américains qui ont été tués par la police
au cours des dernières deux années et demi.
Vous ignorez peut-être
que, dans l'autre liste, ce sont également des Afro-américains
qui ont été tués au cours des deux dernières années.
Une seule chose distingue les noms que vous connaissez
des noms que vous ne connaissez pas :
le sexe.
Je vais commencer par vous dire qu'il n'y a rien de distinct
concernant ce public
qui explique le schéma de reconnaissance que nous venons d'observer.
J'ai fait cet exercice des dizaines de fois à travers le pays.
Je l'ai fait avec des organisations de droits des femmes,
avec des groupes pour les droits civils,
avec des professeurs, avec des étudiants,
avec des psychologues, avec des sociologues
et même avec des membres progressistes du Congrès.
Partout, la connaissance du niveau de violence policière
à laquelle font face les femmes noires
est extrêmement basse.
Il est surprenant que ce soit le cas.
Il y a deux problèmes en cause ici.
Il y a la violence policière envers les Afro-américains
et il y a la violence envers les femmes,
deux problèmes dont on a beaucoup parlé récemment.
Mais quand nous pensons à qui est impliqué dans ces problèmes,
quand nous pensons à qui est victimisé par ces problèmes,
le nom de ces femmes noires ne nous vient jamais à l'esprit.
Des experts en communication nous diraient
que les faits ne collent pas aux cadres disponibles,
les gens ont du mal à incorporer de nouveaux faits
dans leur façon de penser à un problème.
Les noms de ces femmes ont échappés à la notoriété
car il n'y a pas de cadre dans lequel nous pourrions les voir,
pas de cadre pour que nous nous en souvenions,
pas de cadre pour que nous les gardions.
La conséquence en est
qu'ils ne font pas la une des infos,
les décideurs n'y pensent pas
et les politiciens ne sont pas encouragés ou obligés à les connaître.
Vous vous demandez peut-être :
pourquoi un cadre importe-t-il ?
Après tout,
un problème affectant les personnes noires et un autre affectant les femmes,
cela n'inclurait-il pas nécessairement les personnes noires qui sont des femmes
et les femmes qui sont des personnes noires ?
La réponse simple est que
cela est une approche d'écoulement de la justice sociale
et que, souvent, cela ne fonctionne pas.
Sans cadre nous permettant de voir
comment les problèmes sociaux affectent tous les membres d'un groupe,
beaucoup passeront à travers les mailles de nos mouvements,
ils souffriront, virtuellement isolés.
Mais les choses n'ont pas à être ainsi.
Il y a de nombreuses années, j'ai commencé à utiliser le terme « intersectionnalité »
pour parler du fait que nombre de nos problèmes dans la justice sociale,
comme le racisme et le sexisme,
se recoupent souvent,
créant de multiples niveaux d'injustice sociale.
L'expérience qui a mis en exergue cette intersectionnalité
était ma chance de rencontrer un femme appelée Emma DeGraffenreid.
Emma DeGraffenreid est une femme afro-américaine,
une femme travailleuse et une mère.
J'ai lu l'histoire d'Emma dans les pages d'un magazine de droit,
un juge avait rejeté la réclamation d'Emma
sur une discrimination de race et de genre
contre une usine de construction automobile.
Emma, comme beaucoup de femmes afro-américaines,
cherchait un meilleur emploi pour sa famille et les autres.
Elle voulait fournir une meilleure vie à ses enfants et à sa famille.
Mais elle a postulé pour un emploi
et n'a pas été embauchée
et elle croyait que c'était parce qu'elle était une femme noire.
Le juge en question a rejeté la poursuite d'Emma
et l'argument pour rejeter la poursuite
était que l'employeur embauchait des Afro-américains
et l'employeur embauchait des femmes.
Cependant, le vrai problème que le juge ne voulait pas reconnaître
était que ce qu'Emma essayait de dire :
que les Afro-américains embauchés,
en général pour les emplois industriels, de maintenance, étaient tous des hommes.
Et les femmes embauchées,
en général pour du travail de secrétariat ou de réception,
étaient toute blanches.
Et c'est seulement si la cour voyait comment ces politiques s'entrecoupaient
qu'elle serait capable de voir la double discrimination
à laquelle faisait face Emma DeGraffenreid.
Mais la cour a refusé d'autoriser Emma à réunir deux causes d'action
pour raconter son histoire
car il croyait que, en lui permettant de le faire,
elle aurait un traitement préférentiel.
Elle aurait l'avantage d'avoir deux arguments
là où les hommes afro-américains et les femmes blanches n'en avaient qu'un.
Bien sûr, ni les hommes afro-américains, ni les femmes blanches,
n'avaient à combiner des réclamations concernant la race et le sexe
pour raconter l'histoire de la discrimination qu'ils vivaient.
Pourquoi est-ce que l'injustice réelle
n'était pas le refus de la loi de protéger les femmes afro-américaines
simplement parce que leurs expériences étaient exactement les mêmes
que les femmes blanches et les hommes afro-américains ?
Plutôt que d'élargir le cadre pour inclure les femmes afro-américaines,
la cour a simplement rejeté l'affaire.
En tant qu'étudiante de la loi anti-discrimination,
en tant que féministe,
en tant qu'anti-raciste,
cette affaire m'a frappée.
J'avais l'impression que c'était des injustices qui s'additionnaient.
Tout d'abord,
les femmes noires ne pouvaient pas travailler à l'usine.
Ensuite, la cour doublait cette exclusion
en la rendant légalement anodine.
Et pour finir, ce problème n'avait pas de nom.
Nous savons tous que si un problème n'a pas de nom,
on ne peut pas le voir
et, si on ne peut pas voir le problème, on ne peut pas le résoudre.
De nombreuses années plus tard, j'ai réalisé
que le problème auquel Emma faisait face était un problème de cadrage.
Le cadre utilisé par la cour
pour voir la discrimination de sexe ou pour voir la discrimination de race
était partiel et déformant.
Le défi auquel je faisais face
était d'essayer de déterminer s'il y avait une narration alternative,
un prisme qui nous permettrait de voir le dilemme d'Emma,
un prisme qui nous permettrait de la secourir des failles de la loi,
qui permettrait aux juges de voir son histoire.
Il m'est venu à l'esprit
que peut-être une analogie d'intersection
permettrait aux juges de mieux voir le dilemme d'Emma.
Si nous pensons à cette intersection, les routes de l'intersection seraient
la façon dont la main d’œuvre était structurée par la race et le sexe.
Le trafic de ces routes serait les politiques d'embauches
et autres meilleures pratiques circulant sur ces routes.
Parce qu'Emma était à la fois noire et une femme,
elle se positionnait précisément à la rencontre de ces routes,
expérimentant l'impact simultané
du trafic de sexe et de race de l'entreprise.
La loi, c'est comme un ambulance qui arrive
et est prête à soigner Emma seulement si on peut prouver
qu'elle a été blessée sur la route de race ou la route de sexe
mais pas à l'intersection de ces routes.
Comment décririez-vous le fait d'être touché par des forces multiples
puis abandonné, livré à vous-même ?
L'intersectionnalité répondait à la description.
J'allais apprendre que les femmes afro-américaines,
comme d'autres femmes de couleur,
comme d'autres personnes socialement marginalisées dans le monde,
faisaient face à tous genres de dilemmes et défis
découlant de l'intersectionnalité,
l'intersection de la race et du sexe,
de l'hétérosexisme, la transphobie, la xénophobie, le capacitisme,
toutes ces dynamiques sociales se recoupent
et créent des défis qui sont parfois assez uniques.
Mais, de la même façon
que l'intersectionnalité
a suscité une prise de conscience
sur la façon tragique dont les femmes noires vivent leur vie,
cela a aussi exposé les circonstances tragiques
dans lesquelles meurent les femmes afro-américaines.
La violence policière envers les femmes noires
est réelle.
Le niveau de violence auquel font face les femmes noires
est tel qu'il n'est pas surprenant
que certaines d'entre elles ne survivent pas
à une rencontre avec la police.
Des filles noires ayant à peine 7 ans,
des arrière-grands-mères ayant jusqu'à 95 ans
ont été tuées par la police.
Elles ont été tuées dans leur salon
et dans leur chambre.
Elles ont été tuées dans leur voiture.
Elles ont été tuées dans la rue.
Elles ont été tuées devant leurs parents
et devant leurs enfants.
Elles ont été tuées par balle.
Elles ont été tuées à coups de pied.
Elles ont été tuées par suffocation.
Elles ont été battues à mort.
Elles ont été tuées avec un taser.
Elles ont été tuées alors qu'elles appelaient à l'aide.
Elles ont été tuées quand elles étaient seules
et elles ont été tuées quand elles étaient avec d'autres.
Elles ont été tuées en faisant les magasins en étant noires,
en conduisant en étant noires,
en ayant une maladie mentale en étant noires,
en ayant une scène de ménage en étant noires.
Elles ont été tuées en étant sans-abri en étant noires.
Elles ont été tuées en parlant au téléphone,
en rigolant avec des amis,
en étant assises dans une voiture déclarée volée
et en faisant un demi-tour devant la Maison Blanche
avec un nourrisson attaché sur le siège arrière.
Pourquoi ne connaissons-nous pas ces histoires ?
Pourquoi ces vies perdues
ne génèrent-elles pas autant
l'attention des médias et l'indignation générale
que les vies perdues de leurs frères morts ?
Il est temps de changer.
Que pouvons-nous faire ?
En 2014, le African American Policy Forum a commencé à demander
que nous « disions son nom »
lors de rassemblements, de manifestations,
de conférences, de réunions,
en tout lieu
où la violence gouvernementale contre les noirs est débattue.
Mais dire son nom n'est pas assez.
Nous devons vouloir faire plus.
Nous devons accepter de témoigner,
de témoigner des réalités souvent douloureuses
que le monde préfère ne pas affronter,
la violence quotidienne, l'humiliation
auxquelles ont fait face nombre de femmes noires,
des femmes noires de toute couleur,
de tout âge, de toute expression sexuelle,
de toute sexualité et de toute capacité.
Nous avons maintenant l'opportunité --
en gardant à l'esprit certaines images que je vais partager avec vous
sont des facteurs de déclenchement --
de témoigner collectivement d'une partie de cette violence.
Vous allez entendre la voix de la phénoménale Abby Dobson.
En discutant avec ces femmes,
certaines ont fait face à la violence et certaines n'y ont pas survécu,
nous avons l'opportunité
de renverser ce qu'il s'est passé au début de cette conférence,
où nous ne pouvions pas défendre ces femmes
car nous ne connaissions même pas leurs noms.
À la fin de cette vidéo, il y aura une liste d'appel.
Le nom de plusieurs femmes noires sera prononcé.
J'aimerais que ceux qui en sont capables se joignent à nous pour prononcer ces noms
aussi fort que possible,
dans n'importe quel ordre.
Créons une cacophonie
pour représenter notre intention
de soutenir ces femmes,
de discuter avec elles,
d'être leurs témoins,
de faire la lumière sur elles.
(Chantant) Abby Dobson : Dites,
dites son nom.
Dites,
(Public) Shelly !
(Public) Kayla !
AD : Oh,
dites son nom.
(Public criant des noms)
Dites, dites,
dites son nom.
Dites son nom.
Pour tous les noms
que je ne connaîtrai jamais,
dites son nom.
KC : Aiyanna Stanley Jones,
Kathryn Johnston, Kayla Moore,
Michelle Cusseaux, Rekia Boyd,
Shelly Frey, Tarika, Yvette Smith.
AD : Dites son nom.
KC : Je l'ai dit au début,
si nous ne pouvons pas voir un problème,
nous ne pouvons pas le résoudre.
Ensemble, nous nous sommes réunis pour témoigner
de la vie que ces femmes ont perdue.
Mais il est maintenant temps de passer
du deuil et du chagrin
à l'action et la transformation.
Nous pouvons le faire.
Cela ne dépend que de nous.
Merci de vous être joints à nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)